[Musique]
salut s'intégrer aujourd'hui je vous
parlais de microsoft et microsoft
annonçait ya pa très très très longtemps
la sortie d'un nouveau produit grand
public s'appelle microsoft surface go
alors la surface go c'est un peu le
produit manquant chez microsoft
du côté des tablettes ordinateurs
l'espace de produits un peu hybride deux
en un c'est aussi un produit qui est un
peu plus cher la concurrence la
concurrence c'est principalement un
l'ipad 9,7 pouces de 2018 qui assez
abordable et aussi les chromebook alors
les chromebook on va un petit peu les
mettre de côté pour l'instant parce
qu'ils sont plus commercialisées sur le
marché américain et pas forcément tous
chez nous en tout cas on va pas
forcément se centrer dessus on va se
concentrer sur cette surface go on va
regarder ce qu'elle est vraiment
intéressante par rapport à l'ipad 9,7
pouces de cette année est ce qu'elle
peut lui faire de l'ombre
si vous deviez acheter un produit
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous devriez
plutôt aller sur cette surface go plutôt
sur l'ipad on va regarder quelles sont
les différences notables du point de vue
technique du point de vue du prix et
vous vous ça veut dire et on y va
c'est toujours quand un nouveau produit
technologique vient d'arriver d'autant
plus quand c'est microsoft microsoft est
une énorme machine qui a toujours su
innover proposer des produits hyper
intéressant alors à la loupe et sapins
coche
c'est un petit peu dommage elle était
vraiment manquantes sur ce segment de la
tablette tablette un peu deux ans d'un
grand public
là elle arrive en force avec un tout
nouveau produit ça c'est super cool
microsoft a aussi planté sur le marché
des smartphones il ya quelques années et
pourrait revenir il pourrait revenir
dans la course
et s'il arrive à revenir en force
vraiment sur les smartphones hélas ils
réussissent leur coup avec la surface go
ça pourrait être vraiment super
rajouter de la concurrence rajouter de
l'offre que ce soit vraiment intéressant
pour le consommateur alors on va parler
aujourd'hui de ces surfaces bio parce
que je trouve vraiment super super super
coupe attends je vous emmène par là
cette surface go j'ai fait tout un petit
comparatif
d'un point de vue technique avec l'ipad
l'ipad 2 cette année parce que cette
surface go c'est vraiment une réponse à
apple par rapport à cet ipad de 9,7
pouces par contre voilà est-ce que cette
surface go écouler ce qu'elle est
intéressante
je trouve qu'il ya plein de choses sur
lesquelles elle est super bien mais j'ai
aussi des points de regret qu'ils sont
vraiment hyper hyper fera lors déjà si
on la regarde d'un point de vue
esthétique juste d'un point de vue
design serait qu'elle est bien réussi
plutôt bien réussi on retrouve vraiment
le design de la gamme surface à
l'arrière vous avez ce pied rétractable
avec un angle maximum jusqu'à 165 degré
si vous parlez quand même de l'abaisser
vous pouvez donc laquelle est comme
l'espèce de chevalet pour vraiment
l'abaisser à mettre comme vous voulez
d'un point de vue esthétique franchement
elle est bien réussie c'est un produit
qui est joli cas l'air plutôt cool
du point de vue de la fiche technique je
la trouve plutôt intéressante je vais
vous éviter d'avoir à me lire à
déchiffrer les hiéroglyphes parce que
j'étais vraiment hyper hyper mal je le
fais tu rencontreras tiff un petit
surface gaudin côté ipad je vous faire
un petit topo du point de vue de l'écran
vous avez un écran pixel sayles de 10
pouces soir on va retenir un écran de 10
pouces
la résolution cdu 1800 par 1200 pixels à
217 pixels par pouce ok ça fonctionne
vous avez un verre corning gorilla
3 en face de sa l'ipad un écran qui
légèrement mais légèrement plus petits
c'est un écran 9,7 pouces bond 10 pouces
d'un côté 9,7 pouces de l'autre à change
pas grand-chose la résolution est
meilleur en tout cas du point de vue de
l'ipad 2048 par 1536 pixels à 264 ppp
côté vous avez 1800 par 1200 pour le
surface go 2048 par 1536 pixels a pas
vraiment mon tout changer l'histoire
on n'est pas un écart qui n'ont plus
énorme mais bosser quand même notamment
en termes de processeurs performance sur
surface go vous avez en intel pentium
gold 4415 y soit 4 gigas soit 8 gigas de
ram 64 giga de stockage soit 128 go de
stockage le dépôt du graphique vous avez
un intel hd graphics 615 sur l'ipad vous
avez la puce à 10 fusion puce apple avec
un coprocesseur ndis intégrer deux gigas
de ram 32 gigas du stockage ou 128 go de
stockage sans aller chercher à faire un
comparatif direct entre nos côtés
littell pentium et puis elle fut sa
diffusion on en toi qu'on ait une vraie
différence en termes de ram 2 gigas de
ram d'un côté 4 ou 8 gigas de ram
bon il y aura vraiment une différence
notable entre le 2 gigas de ram et le 8
gigas de ram en termes de performances
entre le 2 et le 4 gigas de ram la
différence n'a pas hyper hyper notable
entre 2 et 8 oui donc il ya quand même
un peu plus de performances du côté de
chez microsoft
du côté de l'ol sur la surface go vous
avez un windows 10 en mode s alors se
fasse si vous connaissez le windows 10
en mode s
le fameux windows 10 en mode fps non à
répéter c'est une version qui peut
fermer de windows 10 c'est à dire que
vous avez accès aux applications
uniquement sur le microsoft store
ces boissons qui plus sécurisé puisque
toutes les applications auxquelles vous
avez accès sont des applications qui
sont validées par microsoft alors
néanmoins avec lb d'antivirus
parce que si vous avez
des virus qui arrivent par deux email ou
par un autre biais vous savez quand même
être embêté alors il est complètement
possible de sortir cette version là vous
pouvez aller sur une version windows
disent un peu plus classique
par contre sachez vous pourrez pas faire
machine arrière une fois que vous passez
de windows 10 en mode s à windows 10 il
est impossible de passer de windows
disent ah oui d'audition votre smart
qu'il faut il faut le savoir
donc vous avez ça du point de vue de l'
os et de l'autre côté chez apple vous
avez soit à ios 11
eyeos 12 qui va arriver très
prochainement côté autonomie microsoft
nous annonce jusqu'à 9 heures
d'autonomie apple annonce qu'à 10 heures
d'autonomie les deux sur un usage web
email vidéo donc rien de bien folichon
folichon en termes de dimensions c'est
sensiblement la même chose vous avez 245
par 175 par 8,3 mm pour le surface go et
240 parents 69.5 par 7,5 mm pour l'ipad
les deux produits sont sensiblement
similaires un tout petit peu plus grand
mais à trois fois rien du côté des
surfaces godon bon ce point de vue là ya
pas de différence notable sol surface go
vous avez du bluetooth 4 points 1 sur
l'ipad ou stade point de vous avez du wi
fi des deux côtés vous avez actuellement
160 go une seule version wifi arrivera
ultérieurement une version 4g dont vous
aurez donc la version wifi et la version
cellulaire comme ce qu'on peut retrouver
sur l'ipad actuellement vous avez de
l'usb type c'est sur le sort face govou
avait effectivement le port lightning
chez apple vous avez des deux côtés une
prise jack de telles surfaces go vous
avez un port surface connect vous avez à
porte pour clavier tic over surface et
puis vous avez aussi un lecteur de carte
micro sd xc
donc ça c'est plutôt cool chose que vous
n'avez pas sur l'ipad
du point de vue de la photo et de la
vidéo sur le surface go vous avez une
caméra frontale de 5 mégapixels pour
faire de la vidéo en 1080p nos consoles
hd sur ipad vous avez une caméra de 1,2
mégapixels et vous pouvez filmer en 720p
hd quand même moins bien et sur les deux
à l'arrière vous avez une caméra de 8
mégapixels il peut filmer en 1080p
côté tarifs c'est vraiment là où il ya
une vraie différence est là où ça
devient très intéressant est le maître
surprenant du point de vue stratégique
le choix qu'a fait microsoft parce que
sur cette tablette sur cette surface go
vous avez deux possibilités soit la
barre en 64 giga 4 gigas de ram soit 128
go
8 gigas de ram sur l'a 64 giga 4 gigas
de ram il faudra payer 449 euros 99 450
euros vous avez un tarif pour les
étudiants à 427 49 et sur la version
boostée 8 gigas de ram son effigie à de
stockage ça vous coûtera 500 euros 99 et
569 euros 99
bon les étudiants c'est quand même
beaucoup plus cher que l'ipad parce que
l'ipad en version 32 j alors 70 4 gigas
une 32 gigas elle est à 359
mais si vous allez sur la version 128
giga elle est à 449 c'est à dire que la
surface go coûte 600 euros
alors vous êtes à 450 euros sur l'ipad
qui vous a quand même 150 euros de
différence alors effectivement les
produits sont différents les os sont
différents vous avez 8 gigas de ram et
non pas 2 gigas de ram donc on a un peu
plus de performance néanmoins ya quand
même un delta 250 euros ce qui est assez
conséquent parce qu'il faut savoir qu'en
plus de ça vous avez des options vous
pouvez prendre des accessoires en plus
si vous regardez du côté de la surface
goven s'il coûte 110 euros 99 euros pour
les étudiants le clavier coûte 130 euros
et la souris coûte 36 euros et si vous
regardez du côté de chez apple vous avez
pour 100 euros de style et le stylet et
donc 10 euros plus cher chez microsoft
que chez apple et vous pouvez trouver un
clavier bluetooth logitech à 80 euros
alors que vous avez créé pour 130 euros
du côté de chez microsoft
donc c'est vrai que microsoft a comme
une politique tarifaire qui est plus
élevée que celle d'apple ou alors apple
a une politique tarifaire beaucoup plus
agressive sur la surface go vous avez
aussi windows et l'eau c'est la
reconnaissance faciale qui permet de
déverrouiller votre tablette de façon
rapide et sécurisée pas positif pour
cette surface go je dirais c'est l' os
windows dit
avait un vrai windows 10 même si c'est
un windows 10 en mode s vous avez un
vrai windows 10 et ça c'est vraiment
bien
c'est en partie ce qui pourrait
justifier cette différence de prix vous
avez aussi un lecteur carte microsd
c'est pas ça qui va faire vraiment la
différence mais pour du stockage c'est
pas mal alors après vous avez aussi la
possibilité chez apple de stocker sur le
cloud dont bon voilà ça se tient à
quelque chose près et surtout ce qui est
très bien et le point qui est
extrêmement positif sur les surfaces
gosses et vous avez la possibilité de
brancher un clavier directement dessus
alors que sur cet ipad 9,7 pouces c'est
strictement impossible vais le faire en
bluetooth
si vous voulez brancher un clavier
directement sur l'ipad il faut les
soirées hype est pro et a tout de suite
les prix s'envolent
c'est plutôt la même chose justement
pourrait dans le pari fou je vous ai
fait un petit comparatif
j'ai pris la surface go 64 giga 4 gigas
de ram à 449 euros j ajouté un pencil ça
monte tout ça à 559 98 j ajouter un
clavier et ça me coûte 600 89 97
j'ai fait le même exercice avec l'ipad
l'ipad 1 359 euros j'ai ajouté un
paintsil
je suis à 4 158 g a ajouté le clavier je
suis à 538 et d'un côté j'ai une surface
go qui va me coûter avec tous ses
accessoires 689 euros tandis que sur un
ipad à cela me coûtait 538 euros
il ya quand même 150 euros d'écart c'est
quand même énorme alors effectivement il
ya deux gigas de ram il ya 4 gigas de
ram
ok mais il a quand même 150 euros
d'écart ça veut dire que si on veut
acheter 7 microsoft surface go il ya
deux possibilités
la première c'est qu'on n'est pas du
tout apple on n'aime pas du tout apple
on n'a pas du tout envie d'acheter un
ipad on est allergique à ios le côté un
peu fermé d'apple ça vous en êtes vous
voulez pas du coup cette surface go est
aux charges loyer peut vraiment vous
intéresser ça c'est le premier point
ensuite le deuxième point si vous voulez
vraiment un avantage par rapport à votre
utilisation d'aller chez microsoft
d'utiliser cette sorte à ce groupe parce
qu'elle correspond davantage à vos
besoins et à vos attentes que l'ipad
d'apple mais mis à part ça je pas
vraiment ce qui pourrait justifier le
fait de se dire je vais rajouter 150
euros de plus sur un projet qui tombe
sur un autre passe quoi on est quand
même sur un produit qui l'estimaient à
des personnes qui vont aller récupérer
leur email à naviguer sur internet
regarder des vidéos
alors effectivement dès lors vous avez
un stylet pour faire la prise de notes
j'ai des petites espèces fin des petits
dessins sans forcément faire un truc
d'infographiste hyper pointu mais vous
pouvez quand même quelques petits
dessins deux trois trucs comme ça donc
c'est intéressant mais on est vraiment
sur utilisation un petit peu sommaire
quelqu'un qui veut un produit milieu de
gamme à usage particulier pas quand même
devoir choisir entre deux produits avec
un delta 150 euros 150 euros c'est pas
rien et je le dis une fois de plus pour
élever des e-mails la cades et les
vidéos par quelques esquisses c'est
quand même quelque chose donc ça ça
m'embête un peu mais néanmoins je suis
parti avec une différence notable est
sage devant effectivement à tester ce
produit pour un mois rendre compte et
vous donner un vrai retour là dessus une
femme sort en main attendant c'est un
produit pouvez précommander aujourd'hui
sur le site de microsoft
on en reparlera ultérieurement parce que
j'ai vraiment une rencontre c'est une
vraie différence par rapport à l'ipad
voir si microsoft a vraiment bien réussi
son produit alors effectivement
effectivement il ya vraiment des points
extrêmement positif qu'elle fait de
pouvoir le faire tenir axe espèce de
trépied à la microsoft et des pouvoir
brancher un clavier directement dessus
c'est cool lui fait d'avoir un regain de
puissance à l'étude giga de ram c'est
super ça c'est top mais voilà 150 euros
d'écart par rapport à l'ipad
je suis pas convaincu que le grand
public se rue sur la surface go plutôt
que sur un ipad dès lors qu'on doit
acheter un produit
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous pensez vous franchement est-ce
que vous pensez que cette surface go
peut vraiment cartonné et peut vraiment
faire du mal à apple
est ce que vous pourriez aller sur la
surface go est ce que vous contraire
vous dites moi je serais plutôt partant
de rester sur un ipad ou du moins
d'aller sur un ipad
moi ce que vous en pensez parce que ça
soulève quand même beaucoup de questions
et votre tour m'intéresse donc 10 points
tout comme d'hab vous invite à me
laisser des jolies pousse à vous abonner
parce que paris est toujours plus de
teck
il ya beaucoup de choses qui arrivent
donc restez connectés d'ici là soyez
sages je vous embrasse et portez vous
bien
ciao
[Musique]